in a pie in a pore in a tree to one and
welcome everyone to another episode of
genius brain today we have a special
guest well before that let me let you
know that I am one of your host Joe
Jitsu Kawa and right next to my right
for the those are that you are watching
it is David so and to the left
which is your right if you're watching
on video it is a good friend of mine
that I've known for over what 20 plus
years now I'm so [ __ ] long I know
it's crazy and if I were to introduce
him to you back in a day he was a raver
every single one of your interactions is
like this successful mogul we used to do
drugs together yes
networking is where it's at right so in
a donut shop worker yeah
which which which fast forward to today
if I were to introduce you to who he is
he is a serial entrepreneur has a very
successful video game distribution
company called Enix it's insane it's
it's it's amazing it's like a thirty
million dollar a year business it's
[ __ ] nuts as well as many many food
concepts and every time I talk to you I
feel like you're in a whole new damn
business just recently you told me
you're a partner to a [ __ ] VR
shooting experience I don't know man and
ever I swear every week I feel like
you're buying a whole new business so
it's hard to keep up with all the things
you're into but yeah Joey Nagoya so wait
wait you started off doing what Donuts
uh my family or me so I I was actually
in high school I think when when Joe and
I were yep and he had a long luscious
bleached bands when I actually had hair
bleached my hair like like every week
you see a Sun in the Sun in like that go
out in the Sun and yeah oh my and be out
there for like an hour and then oh she's
golden brown and yet these tall spikes
yeah like that's when I first met yeah
yeah but that time I was
you know what's going to high school
barely showed up you haven't raving four
times a week
god damn did and I'm working in the
donut shop yeah I think you were so cool
cuz you had a you had a BMW back then
and I was like you rich oh my god how
are you how are we in high school and
then uhm yeah and then we would just
[ __ ] drug out at Master Dome fun
house whatever and then there'll be the
positive you know Bo after-party at
someone's house and we would end up
doing more stuff drinking orange juice -
to keep it back yeah I'm surprised you
guys brain isn't putty putty or some
[ __ ] dude you guys are [ __ ] crazy
dude and such at such a young age to
just going that [ __ ] ham a little too
rough huh but are we the same age or uh
82 oh [ __ ] yeah okay so you were like 16
I was 14 yeah yeah damn yeah yeah I
remember that time that was like when
insomniac you said throw parties at at
la casa in downtown oh that was matrix
Wednesday's Johnny matrix dude we'd go
party till like 8:00 go to school with
her kick her pants Johnny matrix was
this clearing fog he was this green five
right and his name was Johnny matrix and
I don't know where he got his money oh I
don't know and yeah I just had no
[ __ ] clue but he would throw these
raves every Wednesday night and it would
just be a bunch of [ __ ] high school
kids drugged the [ __ ] out all over the
place and we were there yeah everyone's
and then where's they we do the next
thing Friday we go to massive yeah and
sad yep Master Dome whatever yeah yeah
man that was like the beginning of like
EDC audio tist ik [ __ ] hard all those
festivals now that are multi [ __ ]
million dollar businesses it was just a
piece of [ __ ] like it was like a [ __ ]
little you get when you see how big
raving got it was like such an
underground thing you know it amazing
like it was like you had you knew
somebody that knew somebody that did
that [ __ ] then you got it and you know
what I mean but now it's such a
commercial thing now it's so [ __ ] big
and
they plan out their outfits for months
just to go to [ __ ] agency
do you and we had our outfits we did
pacifiers agloe station shoe box with
that right now I have a mm plush doll
that had blood surrounded where'd all
the time and I had my visor that I don't
want to say it's on it but I had my
signature vise was it puller it's a drop
II would joke in the mall kiosk the
little monkey uh said that embroider
oh yeah and I mean I mean everyone's
more naked now like back then it's like
it was just the it was just the hippie
white girls that had pasties on yeah
yeah but it was like most people just
wore big [ __ ] sweaters and overalls
and like we were it was like it was like
let me be as comfortable as I can for my
drugs it was done you know I mean that
was the whole thing
everyone who plan out their drugs in
[ __ ] instead of the outfits this is what
you guys were in high in high school
yeah I was 14 so how did you meet Joey
then mutual friends I think all the
Asians kind of knew each other back then
there was like I mean you go to Lexus
when you go clubbing or whatever there's
always like that clique that always
shows the regulars so there was like a
group drug degenerate Asians that always
were there or on I love Raven net yeah
holy [ __ ] around I'm pretty sure yeah we
were on those forums like chatting and
AOL rooms and stuff [ __ ] forums doing
chat rooms man yeah those eight they
aimed those able chatters we used to be
up on there I can't believe being 14
years old and having like friends and
taking me out and and and just being
gone for days yeah being off of days
dude I never asked anybody like how your
parents felt about it or whatever cuz we
were all like okay with like it would
happen do we go to people's houses and
then you see like there's no parents
ever either like they're out gambling or
whatever that's so fun yeah but I
remembered this one time I was we
probably did like three four different
kinds of drugs like what acid II
whatever right God and then we were at
this house and IV I remember this
vividly because you [ __ ] traumatize
me joy like we
[ __ ] this guy gave us some weed so we
can just relax right but there was like
prozac in the weed and no remember that
day so this guy so everyone started like
being in patterns repeatedly over and
over and over yeah and then so and I was
on an acid trip to I don't know if you
drop with me but this guy had a hula
hoop and he kept going like that and
then you know how when you throw the
hula hoop and then you make it come back
to you oh yeah so he kept doing this and
then there was a music video do you
remember that music video I see you baby
shaking that ass you know that song yeah
yeah you were repeating that over and
over and over and over then good
memories I remember the least weed
prozac and how [ __ ] up it made us yeah
it was a traumatic experience I thought
I was trapped in this Inception world
you know like a dream world right yeah
and then this thing was going over and
over and over and I was like oh my god I
am [ __ ] trapped in a loop right now
and I can't get out
maybe that prozac triggered our
entrepreneur mindset that I hope so but
they didn't [ __ ] tell us right don't
always sing your we with prozac now that
was some crazy [ __ ] when you were 14
yeah we were like I was 14 and then I
think at that point we were like who
need to get the [ __ ] out of here right
so I don't know what happened to you but
I was in the car with a few other guys
and and then we were trying to get out
of the neighborhood but we couldn't get
out it was like 7 a.m. and we just kept
looping around and I was like oh my god
I'm stuck in this [ __ ] loop and then
we finally found a Ralph's parking lot
and then they were like I can't drive
anymore
I drove too much and it was like three
hours later cuz we kept driving in
circles in this neighborhood and then we
fell asleep and in afternoon like this
this security guard knocked on our
[ __ ] glass and said you guys got to
get out of here yeah damn good memory
yeah that was pretty crazy yeah and then
I didn't see you for like a while after
that yeah so yeah what ended up
happening cuz one thing you just you
just disappeared out of nowhere and then
there was a rumor that you were like a
like a eBay business mogul which which
motivated me baby
but yeah what happened there so after
high school we stopped partying and then
did you stop cuz you just disappeared
long story
yeah no if we talked about this I don't
remember I don't know if I want to talk
about this is very deep actually I've
never talked about I don't know if I
should be talking about if you don't
want to it's cool it's cool
so bad it was gang-related though I
don't think we talked about this when we
talked
oh no I didn't know actually I had to
hide out uh X no one knows about this
not too many but I had to hide up for a
whole summer and after that summer I
think EDC and audit is a game you go
like on Google Images like last Raving
images online like I remember checking
like three months ago it's still up but
oh we after those parties Agati autistic
and like a New Year's Eve yeah event
then I like things happened yeah which
we note on phone yeah we didn't know but
then I had to hide out for a whole
summer so that's what happened because I
had no [ __ ] you just disappeared
because raves started getting a super
popular with a bunch of like a lot of
gangs yeah yeah yeah like that and it
wasn't just about like raver beads and
polarity Oh was it yeah this is before I
was in the gang world but yeah you're
right yeah yeah it was crazy so so
that's I think that's one thing I've
left out but you had a hideout damn yeah
and then after that I kind of cleaned up
and and then you know got out of all the
raving drug scene etc and focusing on
graphic design I was doing graphic
design like self-taught to ham yeah I
remember I was I was uh like before
everything started I was I was doing
like a internship free internship and
helping um what's his name
Nelly Nellie's website Nelly the rapper
yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] yeah random
super random I remember there was a
Santa Monica like graphic design agency
and I went on online one day to apply
and like just looking for a job or like
part-time or experience and trying to
learn and then these guys like yeah we
do websites for celebrities for
musicians and rappers like
then yeah and then I was like working I
had no website experience yeah but I
loved I loved like just graphic designer
art you know and and then I was just
like practicing that and then I was
working on my portfolio and then this
was like and then we graduated and I was
like [ __ ] all my friends are going to
like University Center and I ended up
getting accepted to nowhere yeah and
then and then I was like alright cool
it's gonna go to Community College
mm-hmm yeah and then ended up going
doing graphic design like at Santa
Monica College PCC GCC and then at that
time you know my family still had the
donut shops my family was in the donut
business and Joe knows that yeah
that's why your name was literally donut
Joey anybody from sgv if you know like
Uncle Joe's that was next to Gabriella
no high school at the corner there on
San Gabriel now it's a baseball field
mm-hmm guy really no you better be sorry
about that they kicked us out they
kicked us out oh yeah yeah crazy stories
like they had offered my my dad I mean
he should have ticket some guy came and
offered my dad like X amount of money
like a lot for the space cuz we get like
two 300 customers a day a little mom and
Joe remember that place yeah because we
have like a tire shop next door and
gambling with students I'm coming all
the time and people around the community
it's been there since like 80s you know
yeah my dad never took that and he and
then before we knew that this goes like
oh we're gonna expand out and we had no
option and they're just kicking you out
with a nothing he was like peanuts day
and they had it they just like forced us
out you know and and then what he would
have done that to the guy that offered
your dad money yeah exactly the same
thing so they yeah but all that happened
and then like you know the whole story
about a lot of people know about this is
Jonah King which is my uncle he went
from rags to riches to rags to riches
but his whole donut story is he gambled
everything away he had a bunch of donut
shop wait is he like the original
Cambodian donut king he is the donut
king and he has a book on Amazon called
the donut king really yeah he's
he's he's the inventor of the pink boxes
for doughnuts what the [ __ ]
waiting so he's the reason white
Cambodians own donut shops yeah what the
[ __ ] is we can't bonis only donut shops
man what the [ __ ] is that
it's stereotypical but it's true it's it
it because the whole after the genocide
around the 1978 or 79 forgot all the
Cambodia immigrants were sponsored by I
think Ronald Reagan at that time they
came over to us and there's no education
no English teaching you like classes or
anything so when they came over here
like my uncle Ted was one of the first
ones to come to America and then Ronald
Reagan George Bush for some politics he
got involved in that and he got
investment money to to buy land and then
build donut shops and he had like over
200 of them around SoCal Wow yeah and
then it was smart because as an
entrepreneur for him he would do like a
rev share and like a rental agreement so
any immigrant that would come by he
would sublease the space like to any
immigrant and say hey this is your donut
shop but you pay me your profit share
and you pay me a rent every month so
it's kind of like it's crazy donut guy
at the same time he also helped to like
get immigrants jobs I like windshields
and he helped to build windshields as
well yeah it's all in his book but it's
a quick he's got his own crazy story and
and so basically long strip for him he
like became this multi-million in the
80s which is like probably like a
hundred million yes you're like dad's
brother your mom he's my dad's side
there it's kind of like cousin but yeah
blood-related yeah yeah and then same
last name I see yeah it's art stickers
like my dad had 13 siblings my mom had
12 says oh yeah
the donut shop so let's keep pumping
about that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so he he
built up you know his donut empire and
he was a high roller in Vegas and which
was like pretty much the reason why he
eventually lost everything he he'd like
had this gambling problem why the [ __ ]
does every Asian person have a gambling
probably no agent Asian people but I
mean I have to say the Kim boat I mean
every agent like ethnicity but like
Cambodians like love to gamble I mean
you know Asian czar frou they save
everything but they step in a casino and
all of a sudden this is paper Cambodia
do for casino you know before all the
Chinese used to come down in the 80s at
Vegas catered to Japanese like cuz when
all the companies like the the economic
boom in the 90s and whatever they would
cater specifically to Japanese high
rollers so yeah it was like in in
gambling is legal in Japan so ever
having a [ __ ] black yeah they have
those pachinko machines yeah so what
happened yeah yeah and then so anyways
he was he was gambling and then he
basically gambled everything away in
Vegas and under half underground like
casinos and houses and stuff and I think
there's things he didn't get into which
I'm not even aware of a hundred percent
but like publicly through his books you
know that he RP anybody could read that
he just gambled everything away and he
lost his houses he lost all the donors
non-obscene lost everything became
homeless oh he went from rags I mean to
riches to literally rags to riches to
rags and he was sleeping on the porches
Fox a bunch of news outlets did stories
on him people yeah actually like
recently like some other publications
they reach out to me cuz they can't
reach out to him he's in Cambodia right
now he owns like 30% of Cambodia right
now what well that's that's another
story so he he owns so much land right
Cambodia which is a very crazy oh what
the [ __ ]
yeah yeah so you wouldn't black to
riches to rags to riches to rags
it was homeless and he went
going back to Cambodia to get into
politics yeah he made he had some
relationships had friends and and then
he ended up he and he ended up buying
land and things like that so yeah so you
know we got a lot of family Cambodian
Cambodians like one of the craziest
fastest-growing economies right now and
I everyone's over there I had a friend
who just went to Cambodia recently and
he says that there are certain parts
that he thought he was in Silverlake
like yeah it's crazy
yeah as our family they like they were
even I think one of my uncle's he was
importing the don' machines from here to
make donuts over there and people will
buy donuts for two three dollars u.s.
Wow
the price it's like a third world but
you go there everyone's like on their
iPhone on their face on Facebook like
it's normal he was shocked he was like
there was like very hoity-toity coffee
shops just like yeah it's like where the
[ __ ] am i right now ya know when you
picture Cambodia you picture all these
beautiful temple there there you're
thinking of Angkor Wat exactly monkeys
gonna steal my water ball or some [ __ ]
yeah but I mean ten years ago there's
you know you got to go around with like
maybe a bodyguard with a rifle maybe now
you still do but not to that extent you
know you can still you can walk more
freely with your iPhone now and yeah
checking Instagram but yeah it's crazy
so he's out there and he has like he has
another family out there and he's always
in the news and yeah so we got a lot of
family out there and it's crazy because
like Cambodia and like Vietnam they're
going through this huge like industrial
revolution right now crazy because all
the China people are just going over
there everybody every like my face in
there boom that's kind of like the guys
out here that invested into Japan in
Korea like right after the war mm-hmm
they're all rich now only born Cambodia
now right now - yeah a sushi restaurant
to Cambodia they're investing into that
and they're gonna have a boom yeah well
so what how did that how does your uncle
would tie into all of this yeah so so
basically before he had like gone
through he lost everything he had kind
of sold and give gave my dad my dad and
then were very close yeah and he gave my
dad or sold I don't know I really don't
know the exact story which I don't know
if anybody would ever know but we he
gave him like maybe five doughnut shops
in this neighborhood Uncle Joe's on
saying April which yeah you know is one
of them we had two unsung hero Boulevard
the Wonder donut which is now Uncle
Joe's now yes operating yeah the one
that's down the street from the sea yeah
yeah right right yeah so me and my dad
got into that that was uh
1980 he got into that that it's like
when my brother was born I had one
brother and he my brother and I we were
very involved in the donut shop since we
were like four years old so I was born
in 82 we had those donut shops and then
my dad got involved and like day to day
never took a vacation and he worked in
the donut shop for like 18 years no
vacation no days off but we had we had
we had a also and the way it works is
like not even just us even right now
till this day Cambodian and especially
Cambodians who stabbed over jobs like
let's say you have a cousin a sister or
uncle on whatever in Cambodia they bring
them here and sponsor them and then put
them to work and they do any shops not
like as a slave Lee has the opportunity
yes I don't know English so they run it
sponsored they have a job right and then
they can learn English and that's a good
way for them to get in yeah exactly in
the crazy part is like all my relatives
that came here and not speaking English
they're like super fluent after they
worked in the donut shop
see that's crazy ghost training program
that's dope man yeah yeah so so much
yeah my dad was you know his his
siblings were involved in other donut
shops and he was actually always station
and he baked every night I don't go Jose
and my mom worked everybody inside gave
pretty much knows my mom would go to the
market they know her because she was the
lady that was there chatting for hours
you know and then but yeah they would
put me there like five five years old I
was kid I was like drinking my hot
chocolate coffee counting money in the
morning like we'd have lines like at
5:00 a.m. you know damn cuz that was a
spot like San Gabriel was like it was
crazy traffic and then you have the kids
after school and yeah and then when I
worked there I did some interesting
things and building back then it's like
you could get your doughnut and weed
from Joey
that's tight last part yeah crazy man
like especially like donuts now have
changed so much yeah it's not just like
the regular classic donut now people are
doing crazy [ __ ] to that stuff yeah and
like when when because that's the thing
about donut shots because when by the
time I will go to the donut shop
it was slow but in the [ __ ] morning
like 5 a.m. yeah hella baby yeah yeah
it's crazy buddy's grabbing doughnuts
right it tastes different
I think the donut gets worse as the time
goes like and you got to get the fresh
it's like very gimmicky now yeah yeah
and not clowning on my relatives out
there who are doing like all that crazy
stuff but yeah back to actually when my
dad he had one creation and I don't know
if you ever ate this Joe but he would
take and I don't recall a donut but
people he was famous for that he'd take
the tortilla and then he'd put blueberry
or Apple and then he'd wrap it up and
you deep-fry it and then he'd glaze it
like a glazed doughnut what and then he
was known for this apple and blueberry
burrito what this is my 80s like this is
like considered you know like unicorn
food like yeah but yeah it was actually
it's actually really good and I don't
think anyone does it I mean someone
might take this idea oh they probably
will people decide a tortilla with
cinnamon yeah well they do it like that
yeah but that was his like invention
people but yeah yeah so you know my dad
was my parents were in that for like 18
years and and then when I was you know I
was doing my graphic design thing is how
it kind of ties in is you know I was
ready to go to art center and and then
something in my portfolio and things
like that and one thing that happened
somebody stole my zip dis which I was
pretty stupid I had to I had a couple
zip ties that I had a lot of my artwork
on because at that time it wasn't like
you know MacBooks the gap whatever and
some of my good work was on there so
it's kind of discouraging that was one
thing which led me to eventually do
entrepreneurial stuff and then my dad
had gone through the same thing as Ted
our uncle Ted and he gabbled and went
through all this crazy things and
eighteen years of saving god damn it man
my and my mom never certification you
know which was really saddened to me I
was like Oh dance so we went through
some some how did you guys find out hard
times man we musta hit it this is
another podcast
but I could tell you like you know and
and my dad he watches Facebook now so
maybe this will be like face me but he
this is might be the first time I admit
that I knew everything that he did and I
I would follow him he would go to like
underground gambling houses he had girl
hands and whatever you know we knew that
I never called them out you know but and
why did you you would follow him like
tailgate him and yeah I was in these
gambling houses were in San Gabriel oh
they're gonna go great he raised them
yeah because I passed by them in San
Gabriel look yes the focus Plaza used to
be one of why people over here yeah I do
discreet there's like underground
Cambodian like gambling things with like
you know girls and whatever I don't even
know I never went in but yeah he was
involved in that and then like I think
that's where he like gambled everything
away and I don't even know maybe he met
somebody and who knows how far that yeah
yeah anyone could speculate but it got
to the point where basically he he
gambled everything away except for our
house and so he even went into the saved
savings box and so hated thing about it
like I told you three four you can
calculate it three four or five hundred
people a day at even one donut shop
spending two three dollars just in the
morning 18 years you could do the math
yeah million that's million yeah yeah
eight millions yeah that they were
supposed to retire so my mom I mean my
mom is so humble in the sense where like
they came with they came from nothing
yeah they build up all this stuff we
were able to get a house to live and
have food on the table at which I'm very
appreciative and we're thankful for that
and I mean even though they lost all
their savings we still have a house and
etc and I was like [ __ ] like I'm about
to go to art school what I do and I like
at that time actually it was also a
professional video gamer I was playing
speed fighter oh [ __ ] beta testing
counter-strike for valve this is like 96
a.m. yeah I was beta test instance like
98 with them and then this is when cows
strike was like we could do like
bunnyhopping yeah yeah yeah and then I
was playing Cal and and then you know
had a bunch of clans and and I was
trying to make money I was starting to
do that and I made money from that and
giving that to my parents when I found
out then we kicked our dad out of the
house my parents split up mmm and there
was this a crazy time people go through
this you know this is a life thing right
yeah yeah yeah a life experience and
then I was like [ __ ] I got a really
hustle you know so
was doing the tournaments and then I was
like dang I guess you're doing video
games like instead of going to get a
regular job you're like I got a play
video games harder during the time when
video games did not pay well no at that
time there's no eSports like there's no
eSports I was follow you professional
eSports player at that time yeah I mean
that'll file like a hundred people in
that community I know and this was 2000
like this was late for three something
yeah this is like mm mm 2 mm yeah yeah
no playing games it's 98 but 96 well
ever since I was like five years old
Nintendo but like Street Fighter
competitively since 98 99 yeah and then
I had a bunch of college books and I was
like oh and that time they had half calm
which I don't know if you guys were all
back calm yeah which was owned by eBay
yeah they had eBay and Amazon was like
losing money at that time
it's half.com still around no yeah dang
you know I I think if I I had a lot of
opportunities and and revenue channel
tickets you can call them but I went on
half calm and I had like you know you
have your like general studies whatever
they call him yeah at Santa Monica and
and and there was even a local bookstore
there in San as near SMC that like I
would buy books online and I do like
two-way trading in a way right yeah and
I buy them and I sell them for like
obviously as a profit we provide for 50
I by itself or 65 whatever and I started
doing that online I was selling it and
then next thing I know like [ __ ] what
else I found around the house to sell
that's how I got into eBay - yeah yeah
yeah and I was like [ __ ] like at that
time I had a girlfriend and her sister
for some reason had thousands of
prenatal vitamins that weren't expired
and and then she had like porcelain
dolls and things like that and I sold
all those things I just listed them on
eBay wherever I could I put them on so
my my use books like whatever is around
the house yeah put those online and then
you know I was like [ __ ] you know I'm
starting to like make some money and
give my parents you know somebody from
that and then at that same time I still
need to make some money and then I ended
up
applying for my first and only corporate
job which I worked at Blockbuster Video
this podcast is brought to you by
audible audible has the world's largest
selection of audio books and audio
entertainment including audible
originals audible originals our stories
created exclusively for audio including
documentaries exclusive audio books and
scripted shows that you cannot hear any
where else you can listen to this at the
gym while shopping in the car traveling
and basically anytime you can't read you
can listen with audible currently the
book that I am on is the game of desire
by Shannon Bodrum Shannon Bodrum is an
amazing woman specifically when it comes
to that game of dating and getting
things that you want out of these
relationships and these dating
situations now I'm not dating but it's
still a fascinating book and it's
something that I like to Dibble dabble
in so shout out to Shannon and shout-out
to audible for that wonderful wonderful
listen so check it out my friends okay
so with audible for my listeners I'm
gonna give y'all something a little
special special special right so you can
start listening with a 30 day honorable
trial choose one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free just
visit audible.com slash GB or txt GB -
500 500 once again start listening you
can start listening start listening all
right - a 30 day audible trial choose
one audiobook and two audible originals
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
GB or Tex GB - 500 500 and get to
listening today yeah yeah and then it
was the blockbuster on Lake Avenue in
Pasadena and I remember that like so I
had my my polo that I wore every day and
and then I worked only for six months
and I mean it was a good experience and
basically I worked there became the
number-one salesperson that the Pirates
Caribbean DVD okay Jose heard this story
many times but David okay you know the
whole story yeah so a good story too
thank you and so I became the number-one
salesperson just as a cashier you know I
don't have you ever worked at any like
corporate retail yeah Men's Warehouse
Macy's do they make you go through like
a ten step checkout process if you work
the POS we're like yeah well we yeah we
had a mono ten step but we had a whole
checkout thing before we yeah like oh
hey how you doing it did you find
everything okay yeah yeah so how to do
that right but I am always selling parts
Caribbean DVD and I was they said I was
the number one seller in SoCal what the
[ __ ] for selling so many yeah you know
because almost every customer I'd get
them to subscribe or whatever you call
that and buy it or yeah or sell like a
subscription car whatever they were
selling at that time they would never
get Commission and then at the same time
when I first started I had to clean the
bathroom for like two weeks and and I
was like I signed them for a cashier job
yeah not a janitorial you know yeah and
I told myself that okay number one if if
I had a salesperson or have had people
that worked hard I would compensate them
properly
yeah you should in a yeah proper company
and then I wouldn't make someone who
sign up for Kasia to go clean bathroom
that's why they have janitors and
custodians right yeah yeah so that
happened and I kind of got like pissed
at that you know it's hard for me and
then people people who know me it's hard
for me to get me get me angry about
something I've never seen you angry no
matter if you ever when you get scammed
and [ __ ] over you don't get angry
ecstasy's in his blood
[Laughter]
Caribbean DVD player he's telling me
stories of how he [ __ ] over and he's
smiling about it and I'm like what's
going on so so I was like all right
screw this and then you know at the town
selling on ebay so while I'm hustling I
was there I was they would put me to
work all the time was just cool I got
hours whatever you know and I wanted to
work towards manage and they started me
putting on the float they put me on the
floor - like rearrange stuff and then at
that time they they were selling
previously viewed DVDs and those are
like let's say Lord of the Ring Twin
Towers those they go up for 25 at that
time that's what DVDs went for and then
they'd sell for like 6 bucks yeah so you
know I started to think I had a friend
that made DVD cases and then and I was
selling on half out of the ocean maybe I
can sell DVDs and then I take I'd buy
all the stock they had at that time they
had there was a few movies mainly it was
a Lord of the Rings that I bought and I
bought like hundreds of them yeah I had
packaged them I bought a heat sealer on
eBay
I'd repackaged them brand-new and boom
put them on and a half common Amazon for
brand new and I would sell I sold all of
my twenty five thirty bucks
Wow there was a big drought of Lord of
the Rings at that time which was like it
was like that it's similar to like if
you're slinging Ian yeah when it was
five bucks now it's out yourself a forty
dollar you know and I took that
philosophy so I give credit to you know
at that times where people consider like
a raving drugs are bad but those are all
life experience that I took with me
right means I do right so from the first
stage of raving and Elvis and then going
into to this business world yeah and
then applying that to my e-commerce and
then yeah and then the next thing I knew
like six months into my job the regional
manager they're like oh hey they they
want to meet you tomorrow are cool
probably promotion you know if I become
manager yeah and then we went to them
into the room and she was like what are
all these transactions I was like oh I
just bought it for families and friends
and on the next day I just I called the
managers like hey I'm out and didn't
show up and then Wow
yeah all right [ __ ] what do I do I put
another job I do like Petco why did you
decide to quit did you feel weird about
yeah I was awkward after that because
then people were like dude this guy's
doing something crazy shady yeah yeah
what I mean I bought and straight out
though I wasn't like takings a dollar DV
like buying them but I'll yeah yeah I
could do whatever all right that's true
but it was the same title though yeah
yeah yeah well it's cooler not like [ __ ]
what else can I sell what does I do and
I try to apply to other like jaws Petco
and like everywhere yeah I think like ah
Sh Home Depot and I didn't get a job
like whatever's good this so I started
to like expand my online thing and that
you know I'm still playing Street
Fighter whatever so I went online bought
a ps2 controller and this is like that
controller is like I think what launched
my business career and it was a $5 blue
transparent blue piece yeah you know it
looks like a Sony controller well they
call him in China one to one epe but
100% like the Sony no sony logo I was
like cool it's like official and I play
is like oh this is junk you know so yeah
went back online sold it for 20 bucks I
was like I was put at 20 sell for 20 she
sold it for more yeah so for it was five
sold for 20 bucks well I remember the
sellers name was cat from Mars and then
uh here's from Florida there's a bunch
of Asian guys like I think from Hong
Kong or China and they lived in Florida
and they were doing trading whatever and
I didn't know I don't know anything
about wholesale or anything yeah so I
went to him and he had he he had a bunch
of packages like like three controllers
and a multi-tap you guys were in
multi-plug for controls yeah that 20
bucks so three control isn't that for 20
bucks free shipping I was like Dan what
a deal so I bought that and I was like
damn this is junk went back online 20
bucks each I separated it so basically
2000s Ben and I me and I sold for 80
bucks okay $60 profit I was like [ __ ]
went back whatever money I had from
Blockbuster was like five six straight
bucks seven hundred something exactly
and then boom you just resell the
product yeah we're selling on eBay yeah
and then I started doing a lot of
research what he'd be like so I realized
every seller had like four or five six
seven accounts and I went to all the
accounts bought all those inventory
resold everything started competing with
them all right cool so you're competing
by buying their own products and they're
selling it for a higher price
yeah how the [ __ ] did you do that but it
worked you know oh yeah which is crazy
so people could have got the same
controller for any price anybody could
could do that but at that time eBay and
I think Joey you've had experience at
eBay
like at that time 2004
or to 2007/8 it was a like I think that
was a base primetime where it was
you've you had anything for lower cost
you can i still make money from Alibaba
or wherever now it's like you make
pennies right yeah yeah at that time man
I was making like sixty eighty percent
margins exactly yeah back there was like
damn dude what else can I sell what else
yeah that's how like people like got
into the crazy manufacturing business
because of those eBay uh-huh like like
you know evike the yeah yeah they
remember I had a airsoft company back
there too and they remember my [ __ ] and
then yeah I got taken they still around
no they're round do they occupy
no no evike evike not ebike oh yeah yeah
yeah they're airsoft company but yeah
they're old-school Bay 2
yeah a lot of these companies yeah
old-school you baby I don't have like
crazy warehouses yeah you know and it
came from eBay so anyways yeah and and
and so I started like I opened up some
other accounts and then just like
expanded my inventory so whatever those
guys carried ps2 extension cables dance
pads and then dance pad is where I
really like expanded my company that's
as revolution yeah yeah so we expand
everything and then I was like [ __ ] I
need to like lower my prices to get more
more like you know increasing their
profit margins so I was googling
different wholesalers in San Gabriel
Valley or SoCal LA there's a bunch of
walnut City industry contacted them set
up accounts and then started buying a
bunch from them and I stopped buying
from the homeless because I realized
that I'm getting ripped off yeah even
though I'm making so much money then I
realize I'm getting like and then buy
stuff 50% even less now for the local
sellers and I'm like cleaning them out
yeah I have like three four different
accounts different names because it was
a good strategy cuz once people were
like let's say you go to Amazon you
don't buy from Amazon but you go to
Target right it was that same concept
like I was like I had my Amazon my
target etc but it's still going to the
same bank accounts yeah company with
different yeah it's a different platform
yeah yeah you know see that's genius I
never did that yeah they flew that on
Amazon
with electronics like oh yeah they do
yeah and they [ __ ] get my ass every
time yeah it's all it's all different
brands with the same company it's so
funny because there was this there was a
specific charger that I liked like a
portable charger that had a wall plug in
but it had six different cords attached
to it and it just suddenly just
disappeared went out of stock and then I
saw another I popped the begin but a
different company name I was like oh
that's the same but I still buy it I
just bought it twice over dude smart
yeah yeah yeah but that's how they get
you
yeah so had a bunch of accounts and then
after the wholesalers I was like [ __ ] I
got to continue to cut the cost so I
went to Alibaba one day and then I just
like googled all the stuff that was
selling like crazy and our number one
item actually ended up being DDR Dan
spent like foam ones thin ones metal
dance pads that were sold at Fry's
Electronics and so what happened was I
found this guy I did a lot of a lot of
digging he's still in the gaming
business but just some random guy that
was on Alibaba and he was like oh I make
them and here's the price like damn is
it really the price was like 30 bucks
and I did sell dance pads for 200 the
metal Wow yeah and then and cuz we would
buy pallets of them and and then what
what happened was we ended up just
sending this got all this money and then
from the first year I went from that for
five six seven hundred to like two three
million dollars just shipping thousands
of packages a day by myself
I mean my brother has [ __ ] yeah I
wake up in the morning have 30,000 my
PayPal account every day
holy other son this was I was 20 21 oh
my god dude yes [ __ ] I didn't know
what to do man yeah and my brother you
know he went to business school whatever
and I don't know one brother and I was
like alright cool you come and help me
like this part-time and then he ended up
quitting his like corporate jobs or
whatever yeah would have to yeah and he
was just helping me because I didn't
know what to do with the finance stuff I
was getting a bunch of money to know
what to do right and then I was like
[ __ ] it just felt casual so I was like
oh [ __ ] I want to now have ten I have
twenty over fifty thousand hundred
thousand and I was like how do i do you
know I it's crazy cuz what I you know
you inspired me to do eBay cuz we would
hear a rumor about you and be like you
know you know Joey made it right and
we're like what yeah I heard he made
like a hundred thousand dollars last
year and were like what and then I hear
no joy made a million dollars last year
and they're like what you're like nah
nah nah Joey made only seven hundred
thousand and then like people were
saying like our mutual friends you know
and then like I hear
again joys of millionaire joy made two
million to enjoy this I'm like I don't
know I haven't seen joy in a while but
I'm like thinking well I know Joey and
we did drugs he didn't doing [ __ ] but it
was also something like I was always
interested in eBay man yeah just know
that someone I knew [ __ ] made it on
eBay gave me the courage to just [ __ ]
try it dude yeah and you did it not at
your level bro but that was my first
step into business - yeah similar story
but yeah that's [ __ ] awesome well how
did you get into the gaming thing then
like what your what you have now cuz you
said yeah it's a it's good it'll
transition into like manufacturing so so
basically you know we started selling a
lot and and then buying Wiest we scented
money to this guy on Alibaba and then he
ended up sending us metal dance pads and
I started I took a step back from
ecommerce I trained all my friends to
sell on eBay and then they all became
somewhat successful on eBay - and and
ran their own stores then we started
wholesaling to retailers like Fry's
Electronics what and then yeah so we
supplied like all those retailers with
these metal dance pads and stuff you
every went to fries and - yeah yeah we
sold all those what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that started from even you know and
then eBay at that time also they're like
damn because I all my accounts for power
seller accounts right and you've if you
guys know what Power Cell is like you
need maintain a good feedback you know
etc and then they actually invited me to
like eBay like office to like common
coach and consult but I'd like denied
doing that because I just want to
continue my business and then my brother
and I after the first year we had our
first warehouse in Monrovia that was
like 2,000 square feet
we'd always like max it out we got our
first container after sending that guy
that money blind I was like kind like a
Hail Mary
you know I sent him all the money if I
get this stuff boom you know we're gonna
make it right like we're gonna double
our profits or triple or quadruple and
then he kept sending us that we said it
we set up a relationship
and then 2006 at e3 expo if you guys
know what that is yeah we had our first
trade show at that time I imported these
uh
game projectors that play ps2 or
GameCube Xbox on the wall it projects
your game console 80 inches on the wall
Wow yeah and I told people I was the
inventor of that imported everything
they had at that time iPod was like
becoming super hot oh yeah and then like
but you were the only importer of it so
then you didn't you know someone else
wasn't gonna be like nah man yeah well
somebody came so so this is the this is
when I like really blew up like in my
entrepreneurial kurz the guy that
actually invented it which he helped
Nintendo bring Super Mario to the global
market I won't say his name but he's
famous he's a Taiwanese guy he passed by
my booth with it with our other partner
who was a government official now in
China that we pardoned with he wobbles
too hey where'd you get that I was like
oh the projectors yeah oh it's my
product I invented it you want to buy
it's like he was like here's my card
this is my product I made this product
whoa
yeah and then and then he's like if you
come to China give me a call he wasn't
offended that's crazy like humble like
Tai Chi Taiwanese dude very very famous
guy that invading industry people
everybody knows it's not that's amazing
yeah you know guy I stole it - no I was
actually buying from his our China
partner his one of his best friends that
was selling it so that's how they're all
linked up those guys in cell they're
like big shots you know so anyways I
never went to China ended up booking a
flight me and my brother we took one of
my brother's friends an Indian guy and
then another Shanghainese guy with us
and then we claimed to like - they were
our like staff you know yeah we were
just like fronting figure I make that
kind of thing you know my going to China
visiting all of our Venice Turkey he is
our manager warehouse manager okay he's
perfect English too
like Joey I don't have Indian accent
they thought so they actually that one
night when we had oh okay so we went to
China wait did they all speak English
like how did this go down yeah everybody
speaks English except for our Chinese
partner oh those guys don't speak any
English at all
dang no one works up for like hello so
did you have to have a translator there
or did you have to learn so so the
Taiwanese guide which was my mentor he
he actually spoke fluent English he
actually was a PhD student in Notre
Dame's Oh God amazing yeah so we ended
up going to China visiting all our
vendors and we made our last stop - in
Shenzhen area which which they had their
factory there right next to Foxconn and
it was an area called long haul so
anyways we go there we meet him he said
well you actually made it we go you know
in China people know TV I don't know if
you've been trying to been to these kind
of dinners or do but you go to China
they take you to roundtable order like
2030 dishes waste all that food which is
sad but and they make you drink a bunch
of like by Joe rice wine I never did
this in China yeah yeah but this is like
everyday and I lived this life like
we'll get that a little bit but we we
drank and we went to you know sing
karaoke and do all China things that
yeah there in China and then you spent
like a week with him and he was like hey
you know like I think we could partner
up and do something I was like wow
really okay and then next thing I know
we had joint ventures open up two
factories together yeah and then 2008 I
launched my first video game console I
mean I we got the original chipsets that
was used in like NES SNES consoles and
we watched her first game console 2008
called the retro duo which is my
invention and then I know that yeah you
can find on Amazon that's [ __ ] crazy
dude yeah and like all the games and you
guys I mean people go on Wikipedia like
oh and then yeah anyways but we that was
our first game console and then we just
started expanding I came up with my own
videogame brands and then we just
started I guess like private labeling
and then 2009 they're like hey you know
we really need you out here in China
like I was living I was lying back
between LA and China and then I was like
it wasn't efficient so 2009 I so like so
why was why would they need you there
cuz you're supposed to be a part in
charge of the American side right yeah
so we had our we had our warehouse we
moved where we've gone through it like
five warehouses in like the past over 15
years you know we kept moving but my
brother was he was like he's a CEO and
he like was able to manage everything
and I'm more of like the product
developer or like a vendor relations I
see and I set up all relationships I did
all the licenses and things like that
and we've worked with we work with crazy
licenses now which I can get into the
very end but yeah so 2009 there they're
like my brother was like [ __ ] ditch and
I move out they're like Dan's a big move
you know I'm moving my whole life yeah
you know it's crazy and then I went it
up I ended up going out there lived in a
hotel in in Kowloon side for three weeks
didn't know what I was doing yet had no
office no staff nothing and we ended up
like I was my job to open up the trading
offices in the China offices and within
like two years we ended up having like
400 something people I open up my my
Hong Kong office I had my trading office
in order and I was like drinking like
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday oh
god a lunchtime bye Joe like full-bottle
go to China drink again and then I had
in if people know Hong Kong like lkf in
lung Kwai Fong there's like it's kind of
like mini Vegas so yeah I'd party in
China not party well do what business
and trying to come back for dinner drink
again and I'd party at night with like
friends and being in that scene it was
kind of go raving so yeah but in the
club atmosphere you can see the regular
people you drink till 6:00 or 7:00 in
the morning and then I'd go straight to
China again and I didn't like to stay in
China because of the vibe so people are
like oh you always come in because it
takes two hours to get me to the factory
and two hours back so I commute for hour
dad visits for five six years when I was
in China so it's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah
you like living in Hong Kong yeah then
we're but you were had yet to work in
China yeah so I would I would live I
would live in China which is like like
on the Highland side and I'd take a car
and go straight to churn it was like my
normal routine for our commute every day
why and the smart phones weren't around
back then you must have been bored as
[ __ ] bro no no we had smart phones but I
actually had I had a desk in my van that
I like built so I could work and I
that's how I learned to be very
efficient and they just manage my time
because like four hours community such a
waste of time it is I actually had a
desk that I put a laptop there and I'm
and I'd [ __ ] be listen to your
podcast I've been making out and like
seeing the trees and thinking how do
they get so green and [ __ ] and I've
never felt like such a piece of [ __ ] in
my whole life
I'm like the most laziest human being
ever man like if I find a time to take a
rest I take that opportunity to the max
[ __ ] rest guys no my mind kept
working you know and and my mind works
but my body doesn't I try to stay
passive what I am I'm like sleeping with
my kids but oh my god dude
yeah breaking stereotypes of the lazy
Cambodian did because these parts I
means that's why yeah okay yeah so yeah
you were working in China going back and
forth community commuting for five years
yeah yeah yeah and then at that time
also I was other things that I was doing
mm I mean I grew up ever since a group
in San Marino and we grew up with a
group of friends and you know some
friends that I was still in touch with
like into college or after high school
they're like oh hey you're traveling all
the time you got to start like a blog
you know and at that time I a lie from
freebees had started a food blog at that
time and I started a blog called what's
in my lunchbox I'm hungry mmm and then I
would it was a tumblr blog and it was
like that's old school food blogging
dude yeah 2009 at that time you post
your finger and you get 30,000 like yeah
sounds like an influencer wasn't even a
term back then
so there was literally like 20 foodies
on on Instagram yeah I have maxed and
then you know I carried that along I
didn't think anything of it and today
now it's a whole different story and
that's how I got into the food side of
things too but so you know I continued
that blog I had that time of long and
then there was a couple sites
I forgot the names but they were pay me
for my food photos and then they had
deliverables for me I was like you got
to come up with like three to five
hundred photos but it will still be this
I like it damn it was a hobby I enjoyed
it but it started become like a crazy
jobs after high school but I contained
my blog and then open up the Instagram
and then I ended up like that became its
own organic business you know people
paying for sponsored posts and then I
created this like what I have today
which is in addition to what when I was
doing the video and stuff I had this top
food news Instagram account thing open
up a like hundreds of account running
that and then that was like a hobby you
know just to like promote like this work
is hobby that's a business that's a
whole as business it is a business it's
like when you're passionate about being
an entrepreneur though like that is your
hobby - yeah well this is like the stuff
that we talk about that where I just I
feel like a lot of people want to be in
your shoes but they don't they don't
know how to think like that you know
what I mean because you're somebody
who's very like you do something and
then you could also see the opportunity
in what you're doing and take it to the
next level yeah a lot of times people go
through and they they think that they
have these entrepreneurial ideas right
but it's not the only fall flat on their
on their face but they also don't
realize like the type of mentality that
it takes to look at something and say oh
there's opportunity in this and I can
take it somewhere yeah yeah cuz your
mind is always working it is as much as
I want to shut it off and and I think to
the point that you're that you're making
like it's okay to fail you know yeah
I've failed so many times that people
don't even know where I failed because
it looks like I'm always successful yeah
you know but I could talk about I can
probably write a book about failures but
all those failures and mistakes brought
me to where I am today which I'm
probably still feeling a lot of things
but you're gonna try it right and you
took a lot of like leaps of faith crazy
[ __ ] frightening to me yeah yeah
because like I said it comes up like it
come to China you're like all right let
me get my Indian friend
even know where I'm headed you know yeah
yeah and the crazy part is you know
drinking all the time and being in China
there's all that fake alcohol and
everything yeah
situations in the end Joe knows and
we've talked about the progress but I
had health issues too that you know the
dark side of entrepreneurs dark side of
entrepreneurship you know you got a it's
funny because in China people think it's
like Oh China has so much money and you
go there you gonna make a bunch of money
it's like when people our age or they
come to America they're like oh I come
to America I'm gonna make so much money
so fast but yeah you got to make crazy
sacrifices and I'm talking about not
time but your health sacrifice to make
it in China anywhere but why is it like
like disrespect for you just can't hang
if they go if you go like I can't drink
bro
they'll be like nah still drinking
mother for everything the first
impression yeah the first time you ever
drink with anybody and this is a tip to
everyone you hope you want to make it
either seen one you you have allergy to
alcohol or two you just show like crazy
sickness if you touch any alcohol cuz
there's many that's what I actually have
though I have yeah they don't understand
like if the first time you meet somebody
and they're a China businessman yeah if
you end up even taking a shot and you
seem okay that already set the tone for
the rest of your life with that business
relationship you know what I would do
was so like whenever I had to talk to
people where this would happen cuz Cree
people drink all the [ __ ] time yeah I
take the [ __ ] shot and I chase it
right but I'm not chasing I'm like
spitting dog I did that so [ __ ] much
yeah it's it's people do that all the
time I join them I'll just puke in front
of them all my [ __ ] fried rice plate
yeah
they don't care if you puke don't make
you drink again they don't give a [ __ ]
man I kept on doing the fake chaser
thing cuz it yeah cuz I could take like
six or seven drinks yeah once it gets to
eight nine ten eleven [ __ ] yeah and I'm
still trying to talk to these people
that's the most important you have to be
able to be coherent yes speak fluently
and just before else they go this guy
can't hang cuz he's exactly until we
don't want to do business with him
because what if he was with another
partner we have and that's like it I
guess I moved up in ranking so I ended
up in my last couple of years we were
always with government officials in the
room Wow and you have like nametags like
people don't see this on TV but dude
it's still your
part of the secret Chinese government
[ __ ] dealings man that's some crazy
[ __ ] but yeah you'll be with the local
people nametags and then like the way
this is a strategy and I think if
anybody out there is gonna drink with
government officials you don't make them
drink their local alcohol which is that
rice wine which is water to them you
make them drink like whiskey via semi so
we'd have big whiskey bottles and
they're not used to it exactly and then
we'd give them what if we we'd all have
to take full shot of wine glass filled
with whiskey in one shot
crazy dude I can't and you do that two
or three and they'd be out and then
you're good for the rest of night and
that was always a strategy that's smart
man yeah that's [ __ ] smart you guys
your team would plan this we would
always plan it and we'd get we'd make
sure like our drivers and our bodyguards
or whatever would buy the whiskey
bottles ahead of time for dinner instead
of bringing the rice wine cuz a lot of
times those guys would come bring like
cases of rice wine and you drink all
night but we just bring two three balls
and we're done yeah yeah but you know
all that like I had gone through all
that drinking and everything and I paid
the price and then one day I think this
is kind of like when my mentality
changed I mean my mentality is always
concentrating for the better but I had a
health issue and Jo Jo and I talked
about this before to is I had like a
minor heart issue and that was because
of all my partying and drinking and then
one day so basically lost her sure about
my heart issue I went out drinking one
day and then like it was like this
constant I never took a break you know
and then one day I think it just finally
caught up to me I was walking the border
in China and then I was like sweating
and getting cold sweat and I crossed a
border and when I went to the office
everyone was like oh your face is like
pale yeah I was like yeah I feel fine
and then next thing I knew like I
couldn't breathe and then I was like
feeling like my whole like body was numb
and then I was like dan was tripping out
you know and I wasn't like oh and I
didn't take drugs when I was over there
but I was just drink all the time but it
was just like lack of sleep etc it just
all caught up you know ya know exercise
my exercise food yeah bad bad food and
then like I was my exercise was like
dancing at the club you know
that's more people so my signature in
Hong Kong nightlife was my towel in my
pocket cuz people know I sweat so much
I always have a towel on me or to just
wipe all my sermon and at night my whole
pants would be wet cuz my towel that I
put in my pocket but Trench oh that was
my exercise you know but it wasn't like
the healthy way because I'd be jury
trained you wouldn't be sleeping so yeah
exactly my hydration was drinking more
which no you know so no it was a
surprise you sir survived man I know
this is crazy but you know that was at
that time that was um when okay so you
know I was I was cold sweating and then
they ended up taking me to the hospital
and that day I remember I went to three
different hospitals in 24 hours and so
the reason that happened is because in
China and not to hate on China like
medical like world but that it's just
not safe because they don't know what
they're doing like I went to a hospital
they're like okay you had they put the
EKG on me it just like make [ __ ] up
they're like maybe we were like oh you
liked the movies you know they're like
oh your month your health your heart
monitor is like kind of abnormal let's
here's a shot they shot me in the
stomach right here this is I don't know
what the hell are doing but I let him do
it you know what yeah I was like I don't
know what to do cuz I was freaking out
like I literally thought I was dying you
know that I don't know how it feels but
like you feel feeling you slowly like
just like dissolving yeah and then you
know it's good - I was with my staff and
I was like you know I was crying you
know of course yeah I was like [ __ ] I'm
doing and then I I didn't call anybody
you know and then next thing I know
they're like hey everyone's like and
then someone called my mentor and then
like everybody in China oh hey Joey's in
the hospital like something happened and
then they're like okay you guys got to
get him to Hong Kong and one of my
partners I was in Hong Kong she came got
me went to Hong Kong went to a first
hospital that hospital they like gave me
a shot - those guys didn't know what
they were doing either you know science
2 shots and then like I even asked you
what you got at the other hospital no
they didn't they had paperwork from
China but they ignore that because that
China pay worries of garbage oh my god
you know so it's just like going to
underground like hospitals so anyways I
was there and then like they had like
the heart monitor on me or whatever and
I ended up going to like the most
I guess well-known hospital called
sanatorium in Hong Kong and they ended
up like doing diagnosis they had like
Harvard like doctors and stuff look at
me and they're like I had like a little
clog you know but it was like to the it
was borderline where I didn't need to
get a splint yeah but this is I'm I'm
not even 30 yeah and this happened you
know the way too young for this [ __ ]
exactly and then like you know that's
why it's like you want to push yourself
but don't go too far and always to
consider your health how do you balance
it then because like you're you're a
serial entrepreneur so when somebody
tells you to stop I mean you really
don't know what your limits are yeah I
mean yeah I'll be a hypocrite telling
people to like be healthy but for me
I'll I usually have like ten ten minutes
out of the day which is enough for me
and for a long time because when I lived
in Asia
I flew every two weeks and between LA
and Hong Kong which is like 15 hour
flights right and I would fly like every
week everywhere but when my creative
ideas and my meditation was in moving
vehicles or I do transportation oh [ __ ]
that's so crazy
traveling work on planes I don't feel
yeah it's like my own my video game idea
is my product it is excetera wouldn't
come until I either was on an island and
I rose like wonderful you guys go to
Island to think of something every time
you know I'm like whoa I just I guess
it's the atmosphere and I learned I
started researching you know how to like
everyone has a different way to meditate
yeah and I I figure out a way some once
one day I met somebody who's like into
yoga yeah you got to learn to like block
your your thoughts and clear your mind
you know people who do yoga or meditate
clear your mind and you relax
yeah em your mind whatever they do and
then they're like if a thoughts coming
in you can block it I was like what
sounds like you know some street fighter
[ __ ] whatever but I I just did I moan
it's like I don't even know it's
meditating I don't know what it is but I
learn how to do something that I don't
know if it's a secret so you take ten
minutes to just clear it yeah so so I
would we're not went before I got
married like I would travel somewhere
for even like three four days and I I
learned how to to be there with no
thoughts like sit there and and I'd sit
in like a room like this and and then
clear everything until I thought of
nothing and then then I'd let's say if I
want to come up with a new I came with
I've come up with some crazy video game
ideas you
like where you can plug a Nintendo
console into a Super Nintendo console
like who would think of that you know
yeah like how could you even do that and
like even for me I don't know how I
thought that so in those times when I
was able to block out those thoughts and
learn how to meditate that's how I kind
of had like my healthy session and and
then that's when I could relax and kind
of like de-stress hmm and also food food
cooking was an outlet like like so
cooking that alone time plus the
meditation time or whatever you want to
call those sessions that I had those
helped are when I was in moving vehicles
or eats watching the airplane people
aren't yelling and screaming you know
yeah so like those are the times when
I'd spend those like 1012 hours in the
plane and I'd brainstorm and I'd those
were like my relaxing times you know and
it helped working I'm still working I'm
still working but the thing is so you're
not drinking and being destructive right
you're not exactly in the stress to you
guys this like did you that's not really
relaxing you're still working but I
think like if we're I don't know I'm not
comparing myself to like Elon masa
whatever but I think you know Jeff Bezos
Tony Hsieh for all these guys yeah and
I've met Tony and Tony is very humble
guy I mean everybody knows Tony he
started apple's comm bought out by Jeff
but I've met him a few times and he's
very humble guy very like introverted
but I know he does stuff like this and
those kind of sessions whatever you do
and then take balancing your health
there that's what gets you to like think
of these crazy ideas and businesses and
yeah and then make make decisions that
are risky but you know calculated for
sure and like it's hard for me now to to
get to to do that because I have two
kids but I'll find time like even if
it's two minutes like even if like my
car rides today two hours in the car
today but I had some good ideas today so
tight man yeah so anyways no yeah no no
you're right have to take a break
don't burn out you know yeah I'm
suffering a health issues like that's
the dark side of entrepreneurship
because we don't it it I don't know if
you feel the same but I feel like I'm
not being grateful I feel guilty I feel
wrong to take a break that's how I did
so then so then like I just keep burning
myself out cuz I'm like I never had this
opportunity before I gotta take it like
I feel like a [ __ ] for
whining and resting because it only
takes me one day to make this $50,000
thing or whatever right and then you got
to do it because if I don't I feel weak
I feel I feel like I feel wrong
like I feel like entitled yeah you know
it's like a formal thing you don't have
it now yeah I'm missing out yeah look
I'm more Cambodian than you dude I'm
just like I'm just praying like please
somebody's leave a duffel bag of money
in front of my door last two years David
like we all we all faced burnout in a
bad way in a bad way right like and then
it was like we went through a depressive
state and um you know I think it's a
little bit different because the demand
for our kind of work is also
entertainment and we have you in front
of the camera we have to pretend that
we're happy and whatever like but not
pretend but you know I mean like it's
it's it's a job like you're you don't
want [ __ ] Jay Leno it'll go up on
stage and be like today I'm sad like you
want to meditate right like so
attainments like they're right so but
you're behind the scenes and you it's a
different type of what's what you call
it like demand right it's different
right because we're not we were
balancing art and entrepreneurship
mm-hmm but I could tell like if we were
pure entrepreneur that would also be
really hard to mean you're just a very
hands-on person too because even a
Smorgasburg what are you doing at the
cash register dude what is that about
why don't you explain that to me
right what is Joey doing at the [ __ ]
cash register do that cuz you're not
definitely not the only one that always
asks why the [ __ ] do you fried chicken
easy Sunday I've been at its Morgan's
for a year and a half right you know
multiple companies your time is more
worthy conceptualizing new ideas and all
this stuff but yeah you're literally I
see you at the booth and I'm just like
you love to work so so one thing that
people don't know especially people who
see me as Smorgasburg and I get asses
every weekend they're like well [ __ ]
on the fryer the fryer is a secret
because to me to now everyone knows it's
like my meditation time and I like to be
on the fryer
and then to work the time yeah that time
that I'm gonna fryer I'm only focusing
on one thing but what people don't know
is that while I'm focusing on making
sure the chicken is cooked and there's
enough cycle because it's a whole
process - yeah everything there's a
process and I've developed I think an
efficient process for for the fried
chicken but during that time I'm
thinking about other things and and it's
my time that no one can bother me except
for someone saying hey you need more
chicken that's it and and and right now
like especially those out there Mary and
you guys learn Marian did but you know
having kids kids are beautiful but it's
like I can't be in a house and [ __ ]
annoying I mean no kids you have to and
I'm already [ __ ] breaking down and
crumbling I'm so [ __ ] lazy man like
on this podcast I should be doing promo
for it when an episode releases I'm just
like they know it's out but yeah I mean
it's where I like to be there sometimes
I mean I I don't micromanage that's one
thing that I've learned over the years
you don't do that let trust your staff
dresser employee you micromanage
probably like but that's a lesson you
have to that's a hard lesson you have to
learn I did the same just some business
part yes sir you gotta let your oh it's
gonna stress you too for the studio
thank you this is not [ __ ] cooking
this - shut the [ __ ] up leave let
somebody do it yeah you're gonna you
gotta trust in delegate yeah let people
make their mistakes
and you tell people this because they're
too fixated on the little my new ship
always oh yeah cuz you can't you can't
scale and grow if you don't trust people
yeah I know so unless they want to learn
them the shop themselves and they care
about the shop yes and we have a good
team right now we have people come
they're like damn how do you support all
these people you know we got five or six
people like you know just like other
booths but we're just one fried chicken
booth we have five people there now and
I'm still there just to make sure you
know what everyone's all good but now I
think I've come to the point where I'm
actually not there every weekend which
is amazing for people to see that yeah
you know but I'll be there you know at
least a couple hours just to see things
doing and trying to work on things so
hopefully answering your you're just
always inspiring
man like it's it's pretty cool
self-esteem just dropped so low hour and
15 minutes I just feel like a PC boots
oh boy I wanna I wanna I wanna make sure
people hear about this part though like
the the heart issue right yeah so when I
was at the hospital um it might sound
crazy but and this is what China changed
my up like outlook on life not that was
I had a bad outlook but I had this crazy
vision now it's even crazier and I think
I'm alive now before some certain reason
I'm not religious but I believe in some
higher being okay but I was there in the
bed at sanatorium I stay there over a
week cuz I love the food by the way okay
I think I'm noodles chats to you it was
freaking bomb but anyways people who
know in the household they know the
food's good they lookin gave me that
[ __ ] when you had a heart attack that's
funny
yeah you could order anything it's crazy
[ __ ] fat pork yeah cuz that'll help
your clogged
yeah but yeah we people people actually
go there just to eat that's not a
hospital you know like the you mean like
the Gloucester oh yeah what cuz it's
decent there anyways so like I was I was
this is like you know they were
monitoring me now it's been like two
three days and then I was asleep or not
asleep I don't know but I saw like six
lights right and like I'm like [ __ ]
just lights just all around you yeah now
he is asleep and and then I was getting
closed and it was like you know I saw a
big light six lights and then that was
like they happen for a moment I woke up
no one's around me yeah then I realized
I started think maybe the six lights
were like angels or people that helped
me yeah
there was a light like I felt like I
either could go there and that was it
or I stay here and do my job and my job
not meaning my business but maybe I had
a bigger purpose yeah which I might
sound crazy and maybe drug talk right
now but yeah then I realize like [ __ ] I
I think and I don't use the word pay
forward and it's not about that but over
10 years 15 years I mean do I deserve
where I'm at now or where I want to be
or what think people what people think
that I've achieved like do I deserve all
this am i lucky
or what it is you know I'm very thankful
and grateful and I think people so many
people especially my mentor like having
good friends that still care about
searching when I had my heart issue when
you know and even time about that like
when I had my heart issue the people
that like texted messaged me those are
the people you know that are there for
you till the end
uh-huh how many people didn't care to
even send a message you know they're
just there just to use you and I
realized that it had to get to that
point
Wow you know I would have to say like
let's say there's 10,000 people in my
life 500 people I had 10,000 really
cared yeah and then something like Oh or
just ignore I don't want to help you
until you're better you know yes I don't
want to deal with stress so anyways I
learned a lot from that time then I
realized like [ __ ] maybe that was a sign
like like you know I was about to die
yeah I would literally there was and
then like I have a greater purpose and
and and and before that my brother and I
went on a mission to Cambodia because
when it rains one year of rice crop is
gone and they don't rise for a whole
year so we did a feeling a whole
container with the mama noodles and rice
bags yeah and we it was a it was like a
swamp we swam like 1 1 mile in swamp
water to deliver where my my parents um
have like they grew up when my mom did
and then we that was like a hundred
families and that day when we're on that
mission 100 families after we done it
they bowed down to me and my brother and
I was like I didn't know if that feeling
is like priceless and not like that
saying like along with God or yeah power
that respect right thank you yeah it's
like it's like it's not even like the
Tears part it's like damn I don't know
how to explain these are adjectives to
describe that sit at moment and I was
like I wanna always be in this type of
moment where I can help a family I know
that they're gonna have food so all
those little things yeah and that moment
plus my heart issues and my health
issues I was like okay I've been saved
more than once in my life this is like
my second that the this heart issue that
explains you guys was my second counter
with life death and then I had a third
one later on still had involved drinking
yeah but three chances I mean how many
more chances in my life to
get to stay alive feel like yeah
multiple because those mating days bro
like maybe I'm a cat right yeah yeah
that's true that should be laced we do
still survive no I know but the times
when I actually felt like I was
literally dying yeah those two three
times and then going through a mission
like that I think there is a purpose for
me and all the stuff that I'm doing like
the the business that you guys see or
know and the people out there that know
I have like the video game [ __ ] my
food businesses my marketing blah I do
all these not it's okay yeah they can
make money they make money but where is
that leading to and I think that's what
everybody wants to know and some people
do know I want to do things like in
Cambodia in other worlds and other
countries and it's leading up to that
and I'm I'm 36 Rhino gonna be 37 but
when I hit 40 I want to make it known
that I'm gonna go out there and really
try to make an impact you know I want
people to remember me that that I was
able to change like an industry Society
or something like that might sound
cliche but that's really what I really
want and I think now is is that like my
chance to really like yeah next 2-3
years get everything together exit where
I could eventually and then go to the
next level I see I see life as a video
game to me yeah it is I think you could
do it man I think you have what it takes
yeah but it's that and then it's another
thing I think like all my relationships
and I think this is everything happens
for a reason right all the ways just
that I've built the network that I've
built all my friends and family are
gonna help me get there cuz I couldn't
do it alone no no one can yeah like I
say we're gonna go on a mission in
Cambodia I can't help myself
yeah none of us can you know and I want
to be able to bring people along with me
to do that Cambodia with you yes and to
get there you know I mean you need money
you need to be stable you know and then
like like people are something you gotta
help yourself before I help other people
yeah right yeah yeah
so yeah I'm still working on helping
like myself my family etc but that's
like where I'm trying to you provided
you provide so much opportunity and so
much work for people it's insane like I
think like I got a staff about 30 and
maybe in the in the food side maybe we
got about a hundred but
like you got thousands of people that
you created jobs for and so you know I
don't know if you you owe any
explanation to anybody because you
already did so much greatness right
that's the crazy part yeah cuz I it's
crazy for me to say it but I feel like I
haven't done enough and and then like I
feel like I had people was like dude you
know the normal question for like they
see the business like especially enix
yeah like ah dude we need to retire and
I was like I honestly and I always say
this probably like I've I probably reach
like 5% of the potential that I really
where I want to mean you're crazy man
exactly once once I have 30 million I'm
done forever I will disappear and nobody
will ever see me again do Yeah right
you're gonna get into so many different
hobbies and you're gonna use that money
for other I'm gonna be juggling yet it's
just we're not in this at his level yet
so once we get to that level I think our
minds are gonna snap into something else
oh god man like I just I just want to
disappear you know a lot of Cambodia
with you how about that yeah Cambodia
true I'll go to Cambodia I'll do all
that [ __ ] do that if I didn't have to
think about money I think I'd be like on
your level where I mean what I mean by
it is that so when you don't have the
burden of thinking about what am I gonna
do in the next ten years can I buy a
house can I do this if you don't have
that thought you can start thinking
about everybody you could start thinking
about everyone in the way where it's
like hey man there's this whole group of
people that need some help how can I
bring what I got into this energy but
most people are just trying to figure
out for themselves right like what am I
gonna do yeah I don't know yeah I want
to win the lotto though this is
different stage I mean I think those are
just different levels and stages of your
life where yeah everyone figures that
out yeah eventually yeah that's true you
know and then you'd think of the next
stage hmm I'm always stuck at every
level though what's your what's your a
workday like then in terms of work like
what what happens like I feel like you
wake up and I'll send there 17 computers
around your face and then you're just
like typing all about
oh man okay so it's yeah so one one year
I calculate like I spent I spent more
time in the computer than in the outside
world
yeah and I when I was traveling I was
spending thirty full days in the air in
the airplane annually uh annually so you
spelled one out of entire year hours
wise in the airplane [ __ ] man so thirty
thirty literally around thirty twenty
eight to thirty days I calculated for
those times I was in China back and
forth it's been 30 like wherever I was
one yeah it was like 28 30 days in the
airplane but because of like my commute
from China to Hong Kong my LA and Hong
Kong travels multiple businesses and how
I structure so I have a pretty good
formula and that's why I think people
asked me to consult for the business is
like I have a good formula where I you
know you got to be strict on your
schedule so it's like you wake up before
okay the night before I always have a
Evernote or I don't you guys use
Evernote but I have ever known our note
and I know what I'm gonna do from 8:00
a.m. well not have to wake up at 7:00
because my daughter's waking up at 7:00
a.m. but 7:00 a.m. or 8:00 a.m. until
like 7:00 p.m. and I know it's like 6:00
p.m. I got to be with my kids
so I have to now factor my family time
but every hour and even I'm always at a
week ahead but every hour every two
hours I know what I'm doing you guys
have schedules everyone has a schedule
but I really know what I want to
accomplish the next day and you're
always gonna have a to-do list you know
you're [ __ ] crazy man so I'm a
[ __ ] wind
I'm a leaf in the wind dude I wake up
I'm like take me win somewhere yeah so
so let's say you want to accomplish ten
things tomorrow hmm
and you I'm pretty sure there's always
something on your list that you always
want to do but you never feel sad and go
I don't want to do this [ __ ] ya know I
don't think it's I don't want to do if
I'm like [ __ ] dude what'd I get myself
into then I start to realize like [ __ ] I
do want to do this but I'm I burn out
you know I burn out fight what you're
free and wife and go [ __ ] I'm not
working today yeah all it shoot that
means she was figured it's probably
delicious but yeah
I mean we all fight with our girlfriends
working I was working now she's doing
cpa work but she says I work too much
and but she supports me at the same time
the kids my kids even know yeah that she
just worked just to work for fun she
just because I need to feel important so
so like you're pretty [ __ ]
disciplined is what I'm trying to say is
like if you're I get thrown off track
all the time
me and Sue cuz it's hard for me to do
[ __ ] when I'm angry
yeah I'm so angry I got work to do but I
could do it tomorrow baby I mean but if
I set a goal that I wanna like you
always have that that task or tasks that
you always wanted to finish and you say
I gotta get that tomorrow but you don't
get to it for me it's like I have ten
things but what I learned it's like you
just gotta like knock off like to the
highest priority or the highest priority
one in the next day and then you should
be good because a lot of times people
have a list of 20 things to do and then
they go to the blows hang for the
easiest things to do like take all the
trash I did it okay I gotta go rest you
know tell me right now and I look at my
girlfriend I go you want to watch
Netflix because that's some really good
advice because I think when sometimes
when people set goals they kind of go
too broad and too big and they don't
think about the day-to-day stuff right
right they go within the year I'm gonna
do this as well where does that mean
well it's good to set goals yeah set
goals but it's like like you have your
vision I have I already I know where I
want to be in five years I mean anyone
can talk about that but I really am
every day people don't see they don't
see it but like every day in my life
every minute counts so it's like Joe
asked me to come and I feel bad last
time I was supposed to come see you guys
don't feel bad cuz I don't feel bad I
feel bad okay because if I want to come
on but you know it was just so crazy
things happen yeah I put out fires but
like I'm not saying like people waste my
time but I want to be you because I want
to hang out yeah yeah yeah you know I've
known John for so long it's not even
doing a favor of something but I just
want I want to be somewhere because any
action I take I feel is another step
towards a goal and where does this
discussion and bring us could bring it
over but I feel it brings me and Joe
a relationship and David you and I we
don't really talk but us talking
together it's maybe a contribution to
something in the future I want to enjoy
never no picture of your naked body and
put it on there that's what I want to do
I'm gonna put sharpie marker I'm gonna
draw you right Sonnen in one of their
hair it's cool because like I feel like
the stuff that you kind of learn along
the way yeah is wasn't taught in school
right it was something I learned and you
picked up and you went through a lot of
trials and tribulations to get to where
you're at yeah and so like so I'm like
missing stuff I'm picking up stuff I
can't even I mean he's right dude I mean
he has the right mindset he has the
discipline he has all the things that
every entrepreneur aspires to be but
what happens is like I think life gets
in the way and we go on and off right
cuz like I work in waves like I'll be a
high performer me too high [ __ ]
perform or give me three four months
I'll just hit that [ __ ] hard if
something happens I might become sad and
I'm like I'm sad I'm I want to go on
vacation I don't give a [ __ ] right or or
just something happens and then it's
it's I think the the the key to it is
really controlling your emotions and
your motivations mm-hmm or like just
sticking which [ __ ] it's that big
picture thing - yeah you know what you
want at the end and if you don't do
these things that big picture won't be
completely you're not gonna get there
yeah you know I mean so that's like your
push and that's your motivation yeah I
mean because my big picture right now is
to find that bag of cash somewhere I
hope is doing a shopping camp I'm gonna
dig something up in Angkor Wat this is
this [ __ ] case of just like gold
watch creator army full of monkeys yeah
that's cool man whoa that was probably
Manas like the most informative podcast
it was awesome dude yeah I told you do
is gonna be a great gasps man now you
you [ __ ] better have a listen
here do you run this for 45 minutes to
an hour yeah but that's this is this is
great stuff because every time we talk
about do entrepreneur [ __ ] it's like on
the low level yeah so now this is like
some real entrepreneurial [ __ ] dude
this is what we aspire to be we're like
still
infants ya know getting started
everyone's at their own stage it's all
good yeah I got a long way to go man
yeah you're talking about guys as this
episode of the genius brain podcast you
guys can see us on Spotify iTunes
podcast any type of audio platform where
they're on the YouTube comments below
write comments interact with each other
have conversations Joey
plug everything that you can so they
know what's up okay what do we got you
can instagram or follow me on instagram
joey nagoya you can follow my Food
Network top food news
fried chicken concept eat bolo my retro
brand retro big gaming my plush brand
that I work with Sony that's called the
Stubbins we run all their plush toys
yeah and we we just have a 5-year
license with Sega to read produce all
the retro oh my god consoles and
accessories officially say its people
can see right now in Amazon so we're we
actually making the original Machel Sega
and love Sega accessories and that's
amazing their projects coming out oh
dude I don't even know man it's gonna be
wild what else yeah that's it if I mean
Smorgasburg every Sunday just Fried
Chicken like a simple but don't bother
me well I'm on the fryer oh I'm gonna
throw throw hot soybean oil yeah man
well then I guess we'll see you guys
next time in dude a little [ __ ]
please